hi I'm I'm my name's Paul bloom from the
department of psychology and cognitive
science I'm here to introduce Philip
pitcher to John Dewey professor of
philosophy Columbia University I am
delighted and honored to have this task
I've only just met Philip earlier today
but I've long been a fan of his work
when I was in graduate school I read his
book vaulting ambition which was a very
smart very critical discussion of
attempts to relate morality derive moral
ideas from evolutionary theory and this
book had a tremendous influence on me as
I began to pursue my own research on
evolution and morality at the same time
I was doing this in graduate school my
girlfriend who's now my wife Karen Wynn
was studying children's understanding of
number and I remember being startled to
discover that she was also reading a
different book by fellow pitcher called
the nature of mathematical knowledge and
I wondered for a moment whether there
were two Phillip pitchers but there was
just one very busy one he's published
many books and many articles he's won
many prestigious awards he's a fellow of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences he's won the Humboldt Prize he
was the first ever recipient of the
Prometheus prize for an American
Philosophical Association for lifetime
achievement and in his work in
scholarship his most recent book is
called ethical project and I'm about
halfway through it I think it's entirely
wonderful I was gonna um I was gonna
bring it but I realized I have it on
Kindle so it's on my phone but but but
what he tries to do an ethical project
among other things is sort of is is take
the critical program of vaulting
ambition and and address it productively
asking how should we relate morality to
to evolutionary theory and cultural
history I think it's a wonderful
accomplishment and I know it connects to
some of the topics of his lectures this
is his fourth and final lecture and its
title is depth and depravity so let's
welcome
thank you very much Paul I feel very
fortunate in my introducers I have to
say they've all done a wonderful job and
of course it's not easy being the fourth
one so I'm going to begin by
recapitulating what I think I've been
saying so far secular humanism can allow
value judgments to be more than matters
of whimsical preference it can defend
the potential meaningfulness of human
lives and any superior consolation
religion can provide in the face of
death depends on embracing fiction as
fact yet many people still feel that
something's missing from the secularists
perspective the last they sense resists
clear articulation and so in attempts to
convey what worries them they resort to
metaphor so Charles Taylor for example
in a very big book very big an important
book charges that secular life is
flattened that it's lost a dimension
secular conceptions treat the world as a
plain constituted by physical organic
and human interactions which jointly
generate the secular substitutes for
values and meaning religious
perspectives add something at right
angles to the plane
an axis that links us to the
transcendent giving depth to our lives
William James I quoted him a lot I know
offers a different metaphor he says the
secular like the tone-deaf unable to
apprehend the value of a symphony in
consequence their lives are deprived of
insight into quote depths of truth
unplumbed by the discursive intellect
now my agnostic atheism recognizes the
possibility and even the probability
that there's more to reality than we
currently dream of future inquiry is
likely to overturn some presently well
grounded conceptions
and will surely enlarge our vision it
might even show that the extra dimension
exists and the particular types of
processes linked us to a different realm
something so different from physical
reality as we know it that it deserves
to be called transcendent but until that
dis day of discovery dawns secularists
see no basis for leaping to the
conjectures of any of the radically
different substantive theses about the
transcendent offered by any of the
world's religions nor even to the bare
characterization offered by purified
religion ungrounded speculation and
leaps of faith all too easily distort
our ethical life the ethical project as
I call it and even at their abstract
best they focus attention on alleged
sources of value that distract from the
human realities and the human problems
when the songs are sung by sirens it's
better to be tone-deaf religious people
and those who regret their loss of faith
resist accusations of wishful thinking
when something important's lost by
abandoning belief and when it's known
that the evidence is incomplete
they say continued faith is entirely
reasonable secularists want to know more
they want to know just what their
interlocutors see themselves as standing
to lose when they're told that no
literal specification can be given that
secular lives are flattened or are
unable to hear the music of the eternal
they're tempted to close the
conversation and walk away but I want to
resist that temptation in this final
lecture I'm going to explore some ways
of developing further the sense of lost
religious people foresee in the
transition to a secular perspective the
usual suspects have already been rounded
up and dealt with we've considered the
alleged impossibility of a secular
source of values thus imposed
meaninglessness of finite lives and the
charge of secular inability to cope with
the
problems posed by death what remain
unless definite concerns and my attempts
to articulate them may only testify to
the extent of my secularist deafness but
even if my attempts are inadequate they
may serve to prompt those who share the
religious sensibility to provide a more
forthright elaboration of what's on
their mind
now this indefinite concern can be
embedded in either of two different
perspectives one of these which I've so
far emphasized starts from a relatively
positive view of the secular human
condition secular life is alright but
the religious life enhances it here the
promises of enrichment and depth but by
contrast you might suppose that human
life in the absence of religion is
deeply problematic secularists can only
provide a diluted brew suited perhaps to
the lives of closeted intellectuals they
fortify those who must do battle with
their own demons and with a rough world
by offering cups of weak tea religions
needed to preserve human life from
darkness and depravity depth and
depravity then our obverse images of the
supposed to start with depth the most
obvious way of pointing to the added
depth the religious perspective can
bring is to recall the value of
momentary experiences in which you
suddenly feel a surge of joy
uniting you with nature affirming the
beauty order and value of the universe
subjective reports of religious
experience provide large numbers of
examples often occurring to people at a
particular stage of life late
adolescence at a particular time of year
spring at particular times of day early
morning or evening in a particular
setting familiar countryside under
unusually beautiful light these
experiences are taken to indicate
something important about the religious
senseability showing as taylor puts it
that quote somewhere in some activity
and condition lies a fullness a richness
that is in that place activity or
condition life is fuller richer deeper
warmer worthwhile more admirable more
what it should be
recollections of the experiences
permeate the subsequent life of the
subject secular lives lack this depth
this sense of fullness but people
without commitment to traditional forms
of religion have experiences with many
similar features famous examples seem to
have happened
above tintern abbey or in prospect of
mont blanc to Wordsworth and sherry
Shelley respectively and many thoroughly
irreligious people could add instances
from their own lives they would report
the joy the unity even the affirmation
of particular values of a sense that
this is how life should be the principle
difference between the religious reports
and those secularists would offer
consists in the felt connection to
something beyond often described by the
believer in the categories of the
tradition to which he adheres whether
the presence of that extra feeling and
something significant to the momentary
state is debatable but I don't have to
settle the debate for the heart of the
religious claim is that human life
receives death from religious conviction
and that isn't a matter of the richness
of a transient perceptual state but is
the power of that state to transform the
subsequent life of the subject from
James on sophisticated students of
religious experience have recognized
many alternative hypotheses about why
these special experiences I'm going to
call them epiphanies come about when
they do religious people favor one
hypothesis if PIFAN is our
communications from a transcendent realm
normally hidden from us there's no
reason to prefer that hypothesis too
many to any of a myriad of
hypotheses invoking combinations of
physical physiological and psychological
causes most of which we probably don't
yet know how to investigate or even
adequately to conceptualize epiphanies
do happen but much remains to be
discovered about their nature and their
causes does the religious commitment to
interpreting them as interactions with
something transcendent confer on them a
status that makes their effects more
likely to be permanently transformative
no the enduring power of some epiphanies
to pervade people's subsequent lives
stems from the qualities of the
experience itself not from speculation
about its causes but from the sense of
uplift and unity from the conviction of
an important insight into how things
should be
those who succeed in fixing the moment
in memory and who can later turn their
recollections toward it reap the
pervasive benefits it supplies whether
or not they are religious or secular
whatever hypotheses they adopt about the
causes of what occurred 80 years ago in
a common faith his Terry lectures John
Dewey saw the essential point he said it
is the claim of religions that they
affect this generic and enduring change
in attitude I should like to turn the
statement around and say that whenever
this change takes place there is a
definitely religious attitude it is not
a religion that brings it about but when
it occurs from whatever cause and by
whatever means there is a religious
outlook and function I want to go one
stage further than Dewey and eliminate
the religious vocabulary here as Dewey
confessed in his lectures his
encompassing use of religious vocabulary
might be seen as stretching concepts too
far and that's why I preferred to label
these crucial episodes as epiphanies
distinguishing religious and secular
perspectives on them according to the
hypotheses offered about their causes
Dewey was right however to recognize
that such experiences are valuable
that they can transform the lives of
those who have them and that their power
to do so is independent of the subjects
beliefs about the causes as things
actually stand the motive force felt by
people whose epiphan is a framed in
religious terms might be greater than
that impinging on their secular
counterparts that conjecture might be
true as a consequence of the fact as I
said last time that the most prominent
world religions have had a great deal of
practice in refining their rights and
teachings if they've adapted to satisfy
human psychological and social needs
they may supply environments for the
believer in which the transformative
capacities of epiphanies are enhanced
yet attraction to any such conjecture or
any putative explanation of it ought to
be tempered by recognition that the
effects of epiphanies even religious
epiphanies are often fleeting a writer
who made skillful use of epiphanies in
charting the development of his
protagonist offers a telling example
young Stephen Dedalus having sought and
received absolution for his sexual
transgressions goes back to the family
kitchen and is struck by a vision of
everyday beauty I'm going to quote from
portrait of the artist as a young man on
the dresser was a plate of sausages and
white puddings and on the Shelf there
were eggs they would be for the
breakfast in the morning after the
communion in the college chapel white
pudding and eggs and sausages and cups
of tea how simple and beautiful was life
after all that life lay all before him
the immediate transformation wrought by
confession atonement and epiphany is
Stevens dedication to a rigorous
schedule of rituals and devotions that
drain the vitality out of his experience
although he is remarkable for the
frequency of his epiphanies their power
to stable affect his life is limited the
significance so vivid in the moment
fades
even the machinery of religion itself
contributes to eroding its effects there
ought to be no automatic presumption
that religious believers are especially
predisposed to having their lives
transformed for the better
indeed once it's appreciated that the
central issue concerns the enduring
positive effects of a type of experience
available to religious and secular
subjects alike it should be evident that
a large number of empirical questions
are in danger of being begged do
epiphanies typically have long-term
positive effects do they occur more
frequently in the lives of religious
people than in those of the secular are
the consequences for believers likely to
be more enduring and more positive than
those for unbelievers what factors make
it more probable that epiphanies will
result in pervasive positive
transformations even if such factors are
presently found more frequently in the
lives of the religious would it be
possible to make those factors
commonplace in thoroughly secular
societies only if you suppose that those
questions have specific answers does it
follow that there's a fundamental
asymmetry between the religious life and
the secular life
but the lives of non-religious people
are somehow flattened systemic studies
of these issues would be extremely hard
to carry out although perhaps Paul or
his colleagues will find a way to do so
and because there's currently no
experience no evidence in favor of the
correctness of the answers presupposed
the assertion that religious experience
makes the religious life fuller or
deeper is simply a prejudice a different
but related idea is that the reliant
lives of the religious are pervaded by a
kind of confident secular humanists
can't enjoy start from the religious
claim that values and ideals are
grounded in the transcendent and
consider two versions of this idea about
confidence on the weaker of these the
transcendent grounding ensures the
possibility of realizing important
ideals in the stronger version the
realization is
in the words TS Eliot adapted from
Julian of Norwich all shall be well and
all manner of things shall be well the
thought that the character of the
transcendent bears on prospects of
ethical success is an article of
substantive doctrine vulnerable to the
considerations leveled against litterers
lists religions I went through that in
my first lecture well-founded hope and
confidence require more than the
proponents of purified religion
officially allow perhaps behind the
confidence lurks a perfectly benevolent
omniscient and omnipotent creator who
has wisely designed the universe if so
the thesis must engage a dialectic that
has motivated atheism from Epicurus to
Hume to Dostoevsky Zevon Karamazov and
beyond good religious confidence really
rest on anything so abstract as the bare
thought that a transcendent source of
value contains some guarantee about the
possibility or the inevitability of the
triumph of the good
besides worrying about the basis for
this rarefied doctrine secularists
should also question whether useful hope
could be prompted by acceptance of it in
the face of serious human problems those
posed by attempts to realize egalitarian
ideals for example the usefulness of
hope shouldn't be underestimated if the
religious commitment is to a minimal
version of providential ISM to the
possibility of realizing these values
secular humanism allows a corresponding
hope and confidence but attained by less
dubious and circuitous route responding
to the aspirations of all providing for
every human being the preconditions of a
meaningful life might require refiguring
contemporary economic institutions and
committing ourselves to global
socio-political reform but it would be
premature to dismiss the goals
unattainable and consequently to abandon
hope
if commitment to the ideal is challenged
by skeptical arguments about its unreal
ability skeptic secularists should
listen and they should refine their hope
through addressing those challenges
explicitly reformulating their aims in
light of the evidence rather than
continuing to insist on a quixotic
venture whose possibility is backed by
some abstract transcendent guarantee
commitment to a minimal providential ism
does no harm except when it interferes
with the reasonable revision of ethical
ideals the stronger providential estai
dia that envisages guaranteed success
all shall be well is more dangerous in
its tendencies to induce quietism if the
depth of the religious light stems from
confident serenity engendered by faith
in protective hands that sustain
everything that's a lovely image from a
great poem by Rilke it may be better to
be gripped by the shallower attitude
that clearly sees the horror of some
human situations that lacks the
reassurance of some grander scheme into
which everything fits better to be
dedicated to saving these people who
suffer here and now failure to rescue
them cannot and should not be viewed
from the perspective of some allegedly
grander ethical order in which what is
most valuable is inevitably victorious
the losses are real faith in some future
redemption seems to me an irresponsible
illusion now my complaint about the
dangers of strong providential ism
mirrors one often direct it towards
secular humanism ethical life is
supposed to be more strenuous when it's
embedded in religion
James declares that for those who
believe in a merely human world without
a God the appeal to our moral energy
falls short of its maximal stimulating
power allegedly we can't substitute the
sort of realizing ideals through
benefiting future generations because
James contends this thought lacks the
infinite perspective he concludes by
connecting his claims with the greater
depth of the
religious life this is James the
capacity of the strenuous mood lies so
deep down among our natural human
possibilities that even if there were no
metaphysical or traditional grounds for
believing in a god men would postulate
one simply as a protects pretext for
living hard and getting out of the game
of existence its keenest possibilities
of zest now it seems to me a curious
fact about the metaphor of depth that
some thinkers locate the fullness of the
religious life in the confidence hope
and serenity faith affords while others
like James take it to consist in the
excitement of the strenuous mood so what
exactly does religious belief add to the
force of an ethical imperative an
obvious answer although not the one
James offers is that religion strength
and ethical motivations by presenting
the prospect of eternal rewards and of
eternal punishment but securing
compliance through fear of punishment is
only a primitive form of ethical life
one refined when different emotions and
attitudes were recruited to guide people
toward better conduct further when the
connection between ethical
transgressions and punishments is made
in its most dramatic form as in
conceptions of an afterlife of infinite
suffering there are obvious worries
about the justice of the arrangements
how could finite lives no matter how
blotted by appalling crimes ever deserve
eternal torment how could people whose
major fault lay in failure to believe
under conditions in which the deity
seems to take a willful delight in not
sending clear signals be justly
condemned to so horrific a fate a link
between ethical transgression and divine
punishment can endure only in the forms
already exemplified in secular justice
and whether that could make the ethical
life more strenuous seems to me at best
an open question but James's own account
is better
it improves on gothic fantasy religious
reinforcement of ethical imperatives
derives from seeing actions as directed
towards ends whose significance lies in
there having the note of infinitude as
he puts it I think there's less to this
rhetoric than meets the eye or year
according to James the ethical acts of
the religious believer are directed by a
sense of contributing to the eternal
order humanists strive only to better
the condition of future people a remote
posterity whom they do not love keenly
enough but this is to fall into the trap
of taking ethics to be concerned with
identifying a fixed and final ethical
system in thinking of progress - rather
than a progress from the utopian
condition of future human life has no
great motivating force and by virtue of
the resounding religious language used
to describe it the eternal cosmic order
ought to win the advertising campaign
but the real source to ethical action
and ethical improvement lies in
recognition of the urgency of human
problems ethical life as secular
humanists conceive it is strenuous not
because we care about achieving some
ideal future human state that moves us
as little as the prospect of
contributing to the equally remote
cosmic order what concerns us is that
the lives of actual people people around
us are so easily blighted distorted
truncated deprived of happiness shorn of
meaning that gives impetus enough James
begins his investigation of ethics by
emphasizing the conflict of demands and
this emphasis grounds a different
argument for the depth of the religious
perspective allegedly the attitude and
ethical agent would feel toward concrete
evils when the only existent beings are
finite demanders differs from the joy
felt in facing tragedy for an infinite
demanders sake energy endurance and
courage are quote set free in those who
have religious faith although the second
defense of the strenuous nosov the
religiously embedded ethical life
improves on the first by focusing
attention on the source of the ethical
project aspirations and failures
inadequate response to them its vitiated
by a crucial ambiguity those who issue
demands who suffer or who are in want
might be finite or infinite in virtue of
the scale of their needs alternatively
their lives and capacities might
countless finite or infinite the
magnitude of the suffering or want
should affect the intensity of the
efforts to remedy it we should try to
help those who are most in need so that
our being infinitely lacking if any such
being is conceivable should inspire the
largest and strongest dedication of
energy endurance and courage to respond
to its desperate plight but deities
aren't usually supposed to be like that
they are infinite in a different sense
incomparably greater rather than
incomparably deficient whatever demands
they make don't stem from a lack more
profound than any human suffering the
criterion for the intensity of demand
thus shifts from the ethically
defensible thought that the most urgent
needs of largest forms of suffering
should be met with the greatest
dedication to the idea that any scale of
demand made by a being of sufficiently
grand attributes should be honored and
this comes dangerously close to leading
us to the behavior of the dutiful
functionaries who carried out the
atrocities of the twentieth century
because they were simply following the
orders of their commanders who were far
wiser and powerful than they were so far
I've considered religious life as a
positive in Han sment of a secular form
of existence I'm now going to turn to
the different thought that religion
corrects our deficiencies religious
commitment is needed not
add more zest to life as if religion
were optional seasoning but to rescue
humanity from the darkness of human
nature from the depravity to which we
are all prone my lectures you may think
perhaps you should think like Dewey's
plea for a common faith are pervaded by
a naive optimism I presuppose a picture
of the human subject admittedly limited
in its capacities for responding to
others but able nevertheless to improve
itself to come to appreciate the claims
of fellow beings to reflect to arrive at
reasonable conclusions and in light of
those conclusions to overcome its
indifference
I've thought of human beings as superior
versions of Hobbesian egoists they're
equipped with a little other
directedness that makes life together
possible and with a certain amount of
talent for calm reflection out of that
conception grow hopes for ethical
progress for meaningful lives the
secular replacements for the valuable
ends served by religious communities at
their best but what if we will worse
than that reasonable people mostly but
not entirely selfish might be capable of
the live secular humanism commends but
such lies will be ludicrous fantasies
you might think for real human beings
people with unsteady easily subverted
propensity for reasoning and reflection
with tendencies sometimes to desire
intensely desire ends that would rack
the aspirations they form in the cool
hour perhaps even to harbor
self-destructive urges because of deep
resentment of others aiming through
their self lacerating acts to heap even
greater suffering on their hated targets
real people need the discipline of
religion not to add zest but in order to
tame their demons and make possible some
minimal value for their lives where do
these bleak thoughts about human
depravity come from well from
remembering the extent of cruelty in
recorded history the occasions on which
under the aegis of religion and under
secular regime regimes alike people have
done appalling things to one another
pessimists suppose that this dark record
testifies to enduring sources of human
depravity unable to be completely
disciplined by any social environments
we know or could come to know how to
devise champions of religion contend
that the best forms of discipline able
to check destructive impulses but not to
eradicate them require a religious
framework the pervasiveness of religion
across human cultures testifies to the
need of restraint not in the shallow
form of the transcendent policeman but
in a vivid consciousness of the sinful
human condition no secular surrogates
are available these convictions don't
stem from scientific evidence about the
inevitable eruption of dark tendencies
under a wide range of social
environments perhaps someday rigorous
inquiry will establish conclusions
supporting a Samba vision of our nature
but for the moment those who endorse any
such vision do so on a different basis
some might be convinced by the writings
of philosophers moved perhaps by shop
and house conception of a disruptive
will more likely is the influence of
religious traditions doctrines of
original sin transferred into a more
abstract perspective but I think the
chief sources of pessimism are
interpretations of human history and
human affairs and of personal experience
and the relating of those two texts and
writings that are viewed as providing
the most profound analyses of the human
condition when we turn to some of the
greatest works of literature we
sometimes come to perceive tendencies in
ourselves and recognize in the human
record those the same tendencies and
come to think of them as perhaps
indelibly inscribed do
please inscribe into human nature
secular humanists typically dismissed
these dyspeptic visions but I want to
conclude by taking them seriously like
Dewey I suppose that works of literature
have historically played an important
role in fostering human appreciation of
what is valuable and in probing the
conditions of its realization so I'm
going to end by looking at two
masterpieces that challenge the picture
of the human subject that is figured in
many of my proposals King Lear presents
a world whose gods are abstract or
indifferent
Leah's problem from which the play
begins is to protect the social order
over which he has presided so it will
survive after his own absence from the
scene he attempts to bind others with a
contract that might have worked if those
with whom he dealt with versions of Homo
economicus but the ceremony he contrives
goes awry revealing that at least one of
his daughters is no Hobbesian agent the
challenge of the play comes from its
presentation of want and destructiveness
as more central to human nature than
limited responsiveness or rational
selfishness destruction and
self-destruction shop and house
destructive will well up everywhere in
Ghana rules and Regan's competition to
go to the utmost limit in denying their
father's requests in Edmunds risky
dalliance with both of them in the
transformation of the interrogation of
Gloucester into an occasion for sadistic
enjoyment in Gloucester's own impulsive
dismissal of his son and his equally
impulsive decision to go to Dover in
Edgar's fearful refusal to reveal
himself to his father in Kent's baiting
of Oswald to bring on certain punishment
in Lea's self-exile on the heath in his
tormenting of the blind Gloucester and
in his murderous fantasies about his
sons-in-law even perhaps in Cordelia's
original refusal to substitute
performance
for the avowal of the love she feels
people with the inclinations expressed
in such actions can't be disciplined by
rules and contracts bound in harmonious
interactions provided with the stable
preconditions for meaningful lives an
enduring solution to Lea's problem might
be found if authority could be grounded
in something beyond the finite human
realm Lea's world doesn't allow for that
walls cheerless dark and deadly appeals
to the clearest God's go unanswered if
they exist they are indifferent if not
cruel as flies to wanton boys are we to
the gods they kill us for their sport
the deities of Lea's world if there are
any are made in cromwell's
image but not so for my second literary
illustration while Dostoyevsky's
Brothers Karamazov adopts a similar
vision of the unregenerate human
condition the novel envisage is a
solution even redemption in a version of
Orthodox Christianity committed to
substantive doctrines about the
transcendent the theme is introduced in
the career of Yvonne the clever brother
author of the most forceful version of
the problem of evil ever formulated and
of a poem the parable of the Grand
Inquisitor designed to expose the
terrible burden inflicted on feeble
humanity by the injunction to Christian
love
Yvonne's initial refusal to accept God
accompanied by a theoretical
understanding of human evil and into
confidence in his own power to
discipline his passions gives way to a
later condition of confusion guilt and
horror culminating in his collapse in
the courtroom the reality of evil not
only in the actions of others but within
himself is brought vividly home to him
his reflection on what he has permitted
encouraged and done becomes unbearable
Yvonne's career is naturally read as a
vivid description of the fragility of
life without God Yvonne is closer than
he suspects to his father the insect
Theo de and to his half-brother Dmitry
he takes perverse pleasure in watching
his pupil Smerdyakov play cruelly with
the naive faith of his fellow servant
Grigory looking on the old sensor list
Fiona
displays a previously hidden talent for
reasoning the traits of father and son
are more mixed than their original
introduction suggested similarly the
apparent contrast between cool
perceptive Ivonne and thoughtless
impulsive Dmitry is already questioned
by Dimitri's early confession of a self
understanding that Ivonne will
eventually achieve and by which he will
be broken Dmitry explains why his
efforts to restrain his depravity fail
because I'm a Karamazov because when I
fall into the abyss I go straight into
it head down and heels up and I'm even
pleased that I'm falling in just such a
humiliating position and for me I find
it beautiful and so in that very shame I
puttan Lea begin a him to be a Karamazov
to be a human being is to live in
self-contradiction to feel the force of
impulses that can't be reconciled
Demetrius psychological life is a
fantastic whirlwind blown in directions
that change abruptly he can achieve no
coherent course in his dealings with
Katya and Grushenka in his conduct after
the fateful visit to his father's house
or in his reactions to his arrest and
prosecution the surges of the inner
storm evident in his attempt to escape
Grigory on the night of the murder
using the brass pestle he has owned
possibly snatched up Dmitry hits out in
response to the old servants shouted
accusation of parricide as Grigory Falls
Dmitry jumps back into the garden throws
down the pestle oblivious to the fact
that it lands in a conspicuous place
uses his handkerchief to try to staunch
the flow of blood from the old man's
head and then suddenly convinced of the
futility of what he is doing
climbs over the fence
and runs away Yvonne - we'll come to act
like that on the way to visits magic off
for the third and final time tormented
by the repulsive evil Smerdyakov
exhibits and simultaneously exposes in
Yvonne's own thoughts and life he's
caught by sudden hatred of a stranger
encountered by chance a drunken peasant
whom he shoves into the snow fully aware
that the man will freeze to death he
strides after his meeting with
Smerdyakov afterwards after smeared your
coughs explicit account of the murder of
theo de has provoked Yvonne's decision
to tell the whole truth publicly in
court
Yvonne goes back into the blizzard with
relief even joy in his decision he
prevents the murder he had almost quite
casually committed pulling the pleasent
out of the snow arranging and providing
liberally for his care yet joy vanishes
as quickly as it came back at home he
feels sick without strength and
experiences a nightmare dialog with the
devil how do human lives Karamazov lives
require point and meaning or even any
consistent direction part of the
brilliance of Dostoevsky's novel lies in
leaving readers in the confusion of the
whirlwind so far as the central plot is
concerned the action simply ceases
Demetri is unjustly condemned for the
murder of his father
Yvonne suffers nervous collapse the
futures of Katya and Grushenka hang
undecided the concluding promise of
crime and punishment Raskolnikov's
redemption through hard labor and
Sonja's devotion finds no analogue in
this novel the last chap that turns away
from the inclusive scene around
Dimitri - an apparent sideshow the
funeral of the boy Ellucian that final
setting expresses both the novel's
proposal for coming to terms with
Karamazov nature and a sober assessment
of what it can accomplish
Alyosha the third brother has been
inspired by the elder Zosima to bring
his capacities for love
service to the secular world beyond the
monastery walls
Jasha is announced as the hero of
Brothers Karamazov even as Dostoyevsky
apologizes for him in the narrator's
words he is by no means a great man seen
dispassionately Alyosha's actions are
almost complete failures he doesn't
prevent the murder he was unable to
forestall the wrongful conviction of
Dmitry or to bring the absolution Evon
so desperately needs his efforts to aid
cocky and Grushenka lead nowhere
his sole success lies in bringing
harmony to the group of schoolboys in
replacing ostracism and contempt with
friendship for the dying Ellucian a
Yasha hopes to instill in the boys
capacities for love and forgiveness
fragile and inconstant as they will
surely be urging them at the funeral to
remember the example of inertia and to
be fortified by it
perhaps his exhortation will prevent the
precocious kaalia from following the
path Evon has traveled a Yasha concludes
the novel with a promise a vowing
substantive Christian doctrine the dead
will rise and there will be reunion in
the Hereafter Alyosha is a novice when
apprentice in the religious life for
someone in training the problems he's
asked to address are usually too big
his only achievement is to redirect the
attitudes and the lives of a small group
of boys yet Dostoyevsky suggests small
successes are not to be despised nor
perhaps should we hope for more even
from those who have gone further than
Alyosha those Emma's corpse stinks the
hoped for miracles don't happen
Karamazov life can only be in completely
corrected but the work of even partial
amendment requires Christian love and
Christian hope founded in faith in
Christian doctrine from this perspective
both the Grand Inquisitor and the
returned Christ whose kiss continues to
burn in the inquisitors heart are
right human nature Karamazov nature is
too weak confused irrational and
depraved to allow for meaningful lives
and stable order except under conditions
of restraint and yet any such discipline
must be founded in and permeated by
Christian love a Yahshua's act of
plagiarism the kiss he bestowed on
Yvonne failed to redeem his brother it
was however Dostoevsky invites us to
think the only possibility
well that's literature can any literary
work justify accepting the inevitability
of certain allusions concluding that
human nature is too dark and Despres for
us to live worthwhile lives unless we
subordinate the evidence to blind
acceptance of powerful myths if we join
our Yasha at the gravesite and say we
too believe in reunion in the no
judgments about the in erotic ability of
hypothetical human tendencies of
premature whether they issue from
speculations in neuroscience from
hypotheses in evolutionary psychology or
from works that clearly announce their
fictional status replacing the
structures provided by religious
traditions poses practical challenges as
in capturing all the dimensions of
religious community but there's no
strong evidence for supposing the task
to be impossible unless truth is
sacrificed to illusion better to follow
the Council of pragmatism and the
character of the ethical project engage
in further experiments of living
adapting the conditions of life in
efforts to proliferate opportunities for
all without continuing to embrace
substantive religious doctrines all of
which are almost certainly false or even
to be distracted by faith in an
admittedly unknowable transcendent yet
we can learn from religion and from
literature
our pragmatic experimentation should
neither be blind nor insufficiently
strenuous innocent of the potential
depth of the problems it attempts to
overcome secular humanism might easily
provide tepid possibilities for well
insulated people for Yvonne's who never
stir beyond the salons of bourgeois sand
Petersburg for Edgar's who grow up as
only sons under a temporarily stable and
benevolent social order
looking to societies with special
features small homogeneous economically
buffered it's tempting to think of
religious concerns about what is lost in
the transition to secular society as
much ado about very little consider
Scandinavia and be encouraged declares
the secularist perhaps flourishing the
latest data from happiness research I
think we can learn a lot from studying
the relatively egalitarian societies of
northern Europe but we can garner more
if the study is critical informed by
probing the value of their achievements
for that probing we should draw on the
best available perspectives on human
possibilities and also human limitations
until rigorous forms of inquiry it's
like from psychology or neuroscience say
can deliver firm conclusions judgments
about those possibilities and
limitations can only be tentative
garnered from whatever sources of
illuminated aspects of the human
condition history anthropology personal
experience provide fallible guides so to
do powerful works of fiction some of
them
central to the world's religions for
they supply ideas for shaping
experiments and for appraising them
Shakespeare Dostoevsky and the Bible
don't deliver firm truths to constrain
the secularists project but they do
invite reflection asking us to consider
potential dangers and to take the full
measure of important values secular
humanism ought to be in continued
dialogue with them ought to be
illuminated by the questions they posed
it should evolve through that dialogue
it should take stock of all that has
been most deeply thought about what it
is to be human for secular humanism is
only secondarily secular it is primarily
humane thank you
so I've beaten you all into silence no
good down the road Mark Johnson yes and
basically he's also he's also basically
it has a certain analysis of what human
being is and he comes to the conclusion
that based on this analysis you can
literally literally survive death by
approaching the moral life approaching
the good life and so and you know
there's no in fact there's a lot of
polemics in the book against the idea of
resurrection so I guess my question is
I have read the book secular humanism
that's that's a good question
okay so mark Johnson actually has a
rather complicated position that has a
name that I don't think I'm up to
pronouncing but it's not the same as my
agnostic atheism he's he's closer to
thinkers like Spinoza because Spinoza in
his own time is called an atheist but in
a certain sense Spinoza is also a
religious figure so it seems to me
cheating to be quite honest to say you
survive because there is this I have
this criterion of personal identity and
this criterion of personal identity is
really quite abstract and and if you
have certain kinds of psychological
relations that endure after you that
linked you to things that happen after
your death and you've survived last time
when I was talking about mortality and
meaningfulness I was suggesting that one
of the conditions of a meaningful life
was mattering to others and I was
suggesting that there was a kind of
immortality although shelly kagan lately
later convinced me that that was
possibly a loaded and dangerous word
that consists in your as it were living
on in the memories and actively in the
lives of those who survive you and
that's rather like Johnson's idea in
some ways except I don't want to say
that it's it's any in any sense
equivalent to what the sort of
resurrection or the life after death
that some religious traditions have
hankered after and there are actually
two different sides to this question
which again came up in in in the lecture
I gave on Tuesday one of them being the
concern about your own personal survival
and the other being the one that
comes up at the end of the brothers
karamazov the idea of reunion with
others now whatever Johnson's account
can give you with respect to the first
and I think that's very thin and
something of a pun um it can't do
anything about the second I mean the
idea of encountering those you have
loved and lost again in the hereafter
doesn't come out of Johnson's account at
all and that can't be delivered so I
mean Johnson's position is like mine in
that both of us are in this sort of
wishy-washy middle ground where liberal
Theo theologians and and make nice
atheist as we are sometimes called
sort of stand together and have happy
conversations and so in a certain sense
we are quite close but there are that
but but the views I have been
articulating I hope are significantly
different
partly because I see the problem I see
different problems from the ones that
Johnson wants to focus on he's basically
a matter physician and he's really
concerned with trying to understand how
to develop certain kinds of metaphysical
positions within a secular framework I'm
much more oriented as you can tell
throughout this lecture on the on the
ethical problems the social problems the
political problems and so for me there's
also a difference of emphasis but thank
you for thank you for asking me about
the comparison
I wonder if you could expand on the
point you made towards the head yep you
mentioned in passing this sort of happy
moral Scandinavians yes and they're
commonly brought up and he's where the
discussion is saying look you know
Charles Taylor and William James have
their ideas but it's just false you have
these countries which are predominately
atheist yet are they behave you know
they kill each other less they seem to
be happy to see me live deep rich lives
as best we can tell but you also seem
somewhat skeptical somewhat conscious of
it going too quickly with that and you
mentioned in passing that these are
homogeneous societies I just wonder if
you could expand on yeah okay so look
there is there is a there are two sides
I think to the religious response to
consider Scandinavia and lift up your
heart right one of them is well look if
you actually look closely at these lives
you will find that they are diminished
there's a kind of interior darkness that
hasn't been overcome and it seems to me
that what I was suggesting at the end
was thinking about everything that that
has been written most profoundly about
the human condition in order to probe
this is actually a good thing to do when
people say look they be the self reports
of happiness in Norway so that seems to
me I've actually a very important thing
to do to take as it were the broadest
humanistic perspective into an
unraveling and and a dissection of
what's behind the data there to see
whether there is something to this
religious idea that something is lost or
something that isn't overcome so the
other the other side of it is the point
that I made several times all past song
about you know secular humanism it's
good for people who live in ivory towers
it's good for people who live in certain
kinds of societies then it can only
thrive when certain buffers have been
set up against the early Burleigh of the
world and the hurly-burly of the world
is if not inevitable likely to be with a
lot of it
human beings for a very very long time
and what I would like to do is feel that
there were ways of developing secular
humanist solutions to problems of
facilitating good lives but acknowledge
that and that didn't just simply say
well it can only flourish under these
very careful conditions where where
basically people share many common
traditions and in which perhaps they've
you know intermarried for generations
etc etc etc everybody is related to
everybody everybody looks alike there's
a there is a common culture but
something that can be expanded more
broadly so it can become genuinely
cosmopolitan right so so that was I mean
I'm a huge fan of Scandinavian societies
I think there's an enormous amount that
can be learned from them but I also
believe in this idea of a kind of
critical dialogue between what one might
think of as as the religious form of
skepticism about that as a source of
happiness and and the the results that
come in from the surveys so I want to do
both things at once to learn from them
and yet critically investigate what's
actually happening okay Rick
in your in your first lecture you you
started with some comments about the
fervent atheist and I guess James's
description as he he worships or he he
believes that no God and worships him
firmly am i guilty no then you return
you then you return to this comment
about the you know the characterization
as a make nice atheist the what we might
call not make nice atheists have had a
really big impact in the recent dialogue
in this area and I wonder if you might
take this opportunity to to comment on
how you think your work fits in with
what's going on more broadly in the
culture with aggressive atheism well I'm
glad you think of it as a dialogue I
tend to think of it as a shouting match
actually it doesn't seem to me that
there's a lot of conversation between
dawkins sam harris and co and very
religious people but i share with some
of the reviewers of some of those books
the sense that the the most developed
and thoughtful positions are somehow
outside that conversation but i also
give to people like Dennett and dawkins
whom I regard as the more sophisticated
members of the new atheist group I think
they're quite right to say in response
to some of their reviewers and
interlocutors you're talking about a
form of religion that is you know highly
sophisticated and is supposed to evade
our objections but that's not the form
of religion that's practiced by 99% of
the world's religious people it's not
the form of religion that inspires
people to fly planes into buildings the
form of religion that's out there is
much less sophisticated it's much more
it's much more like our readings of the
religious scriptures because I mean this
the the new atheists are always being
told that they read
they read religious scriptures very
badly that they that they don't
understand that these are subtle texts
and they read them as if this is my
phrase there were scientific articles
well scientific article wannabes and the
response to that is look by people like
Dennett this is the way lots and lots of
believers read them too and that's the
religion that motivates people to do you
know to campaign this is the vital
religion that's sweeping all over the
world that's what we're opposing and
that seems to me that seems to be a
perfectly reasonable and correct point
but I want this conversation I really
want there to be a conversation I want
to be a different kind of conversation I
want there to be a conversation this is
a million point when John Stuart Mill is
talking about the difference between a
capitalist system or a system based on
private property and socialism he says
let's not sort of call one another names
let's try to consider religion socialism
at its best
and liberal capitalism and its best and
compare the two and it seems to me that
what we should be trying to what we
secular humanists should be trying to do
is to try to articulate the best version
the most positive version of the
secularists position that's what I tried
to do in these lectures so these are an
attempt to say all right we're not just
a bunch of of naysayers who say all
right get rid of this rubbish this
religious muck throw it in the sea get
on with life you'll be happier come join
the great Darwinian party and learn to
appreciate the glories of the universe I
mean that's that really doesn't do much
for most people in fact probably doesn't
do much for anybody who isn't sort of
who's the center of whose life isn't
investigating the evolution of nature so
I think circular human has humanism has
to be something more positive something
that's able to to respond to the the
things that religion has traditionally
responded to and has sometimes responded
very well so what I've tried to do and I
probably haven't succeeded beginning
with the first lecture is to work out a
version of religion that gets as it were
overcomes what I take to be the really
sort of serious direct strong arguments
against religious belief against the
kind of literalist metaphysics against
the belief in the resurrection as
something more than the kind of
attenuated think that Mark Johnson and I
want to see so articulate that see what
it can provide for human life going
forward and then see what secular
humanism can strive to provide and
secular humanism has to be a work in
progress one of the themes of my third
lecture was that we aren't yet able or
very good at developing forms of secular
community that is something to be worked
out and work on and one of the themes of
this lecture is that going forward in
trying to develop the ways in which
people's lives can be improved and
that's of course right at the center of
my secular humanism then we should try
to learn not only from the societies
that have made secular experiments
Scandinavian societies we should also
learn from the full range and depth of
thinking about the human and I'm much
influenced and maybe I'll say this
absolutely explicitly by something that
I heard when I was an undergraduate many
many many years ago at Cambridge
involved in in drama I was doing a Drama
Festival and we were performing a play
by Malia and part of the drama festival
was the eminent Cambridge scholars came
along and and they would talk about the
plays with those who were performing
them and George Steiner the eminent
critic came and talked to us and he said
you know completely with absolute
conviction and they were Brooking no
argument Shakespeare
Moliere and stand I'll have told
far more about human minds and human
psychology and human behavior than all
the social and cognitive scientists in
the world combined a challenge for you
and it's an overstatement
I think we have a lot to learn from
psychology cognitive science and various
areas of social science but I think we
also have a lot to learn about the human
condition from the great novelists and I
would say from the myths of the great
religious traditions so I don't want
these things just to be thrown away I
want them to be recognized for what they
are which is myths and stories but I
want them to be seen as pregnant stories
stories that can be used to give birth
to ideas that can be then taken into our
social experimentation and that's really
the theme I was trying to get at towards
the end of the day does that help so I
want a positive secular humanism and I
want that to be in dialogue with the
best forms of religion that we can
construct and I'd like to create a
conversation in which that can occur
thank you
I have to say I think those of you have
stuck to the bitter end deserve medals
but there are no medals to offer you but
at least I think there's a glass of wine
so so so take a glass of wine instead of
a medal thank you